bonjour à tous trois jours piro bonjour
pierre savall enfants et bien oui bon
dit pierrot vous guette havrais nordiste
vous connaissez suppose de p'tit
quinquin
oui bon bien il ya un passage un couplet
de la chanson dans lequel la moment des
pics à 15,1 des petits garçons henry
conscience et sage ouais je savais que
je suis cargo vous souvenez les paroles
vaguement mais elle lit douvrin archi
mentorat du pain d épices du chuq à gogo
sachez que feydeau 12 ans même si après
ça va mieux leur fadeur maltais a quand
même un petit chat ça va mieux
bon tout ça pour vous dire que dans le
nord c'est vrai on aime le chuq
on aime le sucre on est vraiment des
mauges chuq on en met même d'ailleurs
voilà cuisine avec avec le chalet un le
sucre et ça tombe bien qu'on aime le
cycle parce que y'en a plein de sucre
dans le nord vous savez que le nord pas
de calais un chiffre impressionnant le
nord pas de calais et la picardie je
pourrais ensemble produisent 21 millions
de quintaux de sucre par an qui
représente plus de la moitié de la
production nationale de sucre le sucre
de betterave
bien sûr puisque vous savez qu'en france
c'est essentiellement le sucre que l'on
consomme depuis que napoléon avait fait
le blocus etc
il y avait plus de sucre de canne nation
voilà et c'est napoléon 1er qui a fait
planter des betteraves sucrières pour
approvisionner la france en sucre voilà
je ferme la parenthèse qu'historiquement
fin moi le sucre que je préfère je veux
dire c'est la cassonade
ça c'est le sud du nord cassonade
cassonade
alors ce qu'on appelle du moins dans le
nord la cassonade parce que il paraît
que le vrai nom c'est la vergeoise la
vertu à la cassonade
c'est le sucre roux qui vient du la
canne à sucre
alors que la vergeoise les sucres roux
qui vient de la betterave
mais dans le nord et en belgique aussi
d'ailleurs on dit on dit la cassonade
bon c'est comme ça et moi ça a toujours
été mon régale comme beaucoup d'enfants
du nord je crois je me souviens mon
goûter quand j'étais gamin c'était une
tartine 1 du pain beurré avec de la
cassonade une belle couche qu'arsenal
dessus et après trempé dans le café mois
jusqu'à jusqu'à 20 ans j'ai mangé cirque
en bouteille ah ouais ça m'apprendra
réussi mais on met de la cassonade
partout dans le nord on en met dans la
merde en ligne dans les yaourts par
exemple
dans le fromage blanc on en met pour
sucrer les gaufres les gosses on en met
ses très bons aussi avec des fruits
frais moi j'adore fraises qu'on écrase
la cassonade
non mais on a même des fois une pointe
dans les andes il faut donner un peu de
couleur mais partout après ça relève
bien et puis on en met surtout en
pâtisserie alors qu'ils vont vous allez
préparez vous à dire oui la tarte au
chuc la tarte au chuc parce que mon ami
pierre bonté il voulait manger la tarte
au mieux quand il était petit gars me
faisait mal voilà c'est vrai peut donc
non la ville tartan restaurant mais plus
ça que de la crème plus classique est là
donc je fais ma petite enquête j'ai mon
copain pâtissier à la cieux que son père
avait une épicerie une petite
boulangerie dans la rue des postes hier
25 ans 30 ans donc c'était vraiment la
recette même noyé dans le centre place
de béthune mais c'est lui qui vous a
fait là c'est lui qui m'a fait là là la
vraie tarte au chuc hadji tarte au chuc
parce qu'à force de l'entendre c'est une
pâte
c'est une à base de pâte une pâte
briochée donc avec les proportions
classiques 250 g de farine je veux le
dire tout doucement
250 g de farine on met 100 g de lait 15
g de levure une petite pincée de sel
quinze grammes de sucre et 80 g de
beurre un peu peau mate
vous mélangez tout comme une pâte à
tarte et vous vous retrouvez nous on l'a
pas fait vous vous retrouvez avec cette
boule de pâte près alors soit vous le
faites vous même ou soit vous pouvez
très bien le demander à votre pâte y
siègent donc une boule de 300 à 400
grammes voile alors plus simple
bon alors ici j'ai donc de vrais matière
pendant qu'on discutait tout à l'heure
sur les sur la côte d'azur la cassonade
et on va mettre notre vraiment c'est il
faut faire le moins de manière possible
on va le mettre un peu comme une pizza
c'est à dire la rouler à tout petit peu
il l'écrasé que ça m'a un peu la façon
d'une pizza c'est à dire tourner
légèrement la pâte alors là pas de
travail c'est normal puisqu'il ya de la
levure
oui à la lgv est quand même un petit peu
souvent à la maison la cuisine
alors dès qu'on l'a fait elle va lever
obligatoirement en 10 minutes au bout de
dix minutes un quart d'heure à leval vms
est ce qu'il faut faire après on va le
mettre dans la tourtière pour la faire
lever et en bas la levée est là le doigt
levé pendant à peu près une heure vous
laisser une heure dans votre cuisine à
température ambiante
ouais travail et c'est normal fall a
roulé n'a tourné le plus beau plus près
possible du cercle
voilà web un coup d'oeil et et avec vos
doigts
akvo dos on rectifie létale et on létale
simplement comme ça et on va le laisser
reposer d'abord géant pas de borce a
vraiment appuyé comme une pizza
voilà et on va essayer reposer une heure
une heure une heure dans la cuisine ou
le sucre coté à la rigueur pour m'étonne
qu'il a un jumeau bon nous on va
peut-être pas le maître mais si vous
voulez vous laisser un petit linge
humide 1h20 cuisiner au bout d'une heure
vous prenez votre tour tiers voilà
pierre au bout d'une heure
ma patte à gonfler et d'appoint allait
bien et donc on va pouvoir faire tout
simplement de petites tartes à la
cassonade
alors je vais donc prendre 2 à la façon
de madame bon tome
oui parce que enfin la façon
traditionnelle des familles du nord moi
partout j'ai mangé la tarte au sucre
comme vous allez la faire et la réussit
à bien entendu alors 2e de petites
cuillères de crème fraîche pas de trop
injuste
voilà trois à la casse et alors ce qu'on
a fait notre petite enquête pierre ouais
il faut écraser accès doit faire les
petites roues de cette fameuse tarte à
cassonade
ah oui bah ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est
ça c'est vrai c'est pour que le sucre
voilà la fenêtre après enfin comment vds
racing
ouais on est dessus
donc on la nappe avec ce mélange et
crème
voilà ce qu'il faut employer trop alors
on met apex et doit évidemment
donc c'était bien de cuir de crainte
chez moi j'en ai mis 3 ans et dû qu'à
une de trop a deux c'est bien de les
notaires bon et ensuite j'ai pesé sans
ma g de cassonade de vergeoise
évidemment voilà le mot anti turque à
sonnette je vais le mettre dessus
mais comme ces moelleux la cassonade 1
c'est vrai ça se passe bien ça fait des
petits grumeaux de temps en temps mais
c'est rien comme ça ça permet de manger
des petits morceaux au passage alors 125
g alors j'ai préféré prendre de la
blonde parce que les temps donné que ça
va déjà bien coloré si on met de la
brûle ouais si on met de la brûle ça va
être trop noir alors quelques noisettes
de beurre à peu près 60 grammes c'est ce
qui va donner ce beau grand à notre
petite tarte
voilà c'est tout bon et attention ce
fameux sucre away que tu vas pas aller
que quand on était petits prenez ça
c'est les sa s'appelle du sucre perlé
way et qu'on va soupoudré sélection ci
dessus qui vont survivre des granulomes
cette attaque
la tarte au chuc way et c'est ça qui
fait que la tarte au suquet la tarte au
chuc avec ses gros morceau dessus qui
eux vont survivre voilà quand j'ai
allumé mon four préalable évidemment
celle d'une petite dame défaut qu'il
aurait oublié
oui alors j'ai allumé mon fou à 2 sur
222 130 degrés et on va le cuir
normalement entre un quart d'heure et 20
minutes
oui et là tu as
voilà et au fond il n'y a plus qu'à
attendre patience pendant un quart
d'heure vingt minutes
biron j'ai l'impression que c'est ca
point là la tarte
oui je crois que ça y est pierre plat en
feintes à tarte au chuc qui est arrivé à
temps on va tenir sa voix l'arrêt ouais
ouais
alors est-ce que c'est celle qui avec
l'hôte était petit c'est pas pareil mais
il ya tellement de recettes de tartes au
sucre vous avez voilà c'est pas
exactement celle de ma mère mais je suis
resté à bonne ouais je vois les belles
elle est belle et le sucre bien qu'il
soit là et les petits je suis blanc qui
sont au dessus voilà parfait on va
attendre quelques minutes pour la
découpe et parce que ça a l'air chaud
bouillant et on va écouter ça eh ben
voilà ma tarte et chez d'ions à pouvoir
la déguster bières tièdes ça se bosse a
posément j'étais sûr attendre évidemment
lors des conflits légèrement parce qu'il
ya la levure qui fait son travail
ouais j'avais une question à vous poser
ce petit sucre la paire les autres vous
parce que ces principes
on va les trouver dans un fils riz fine
des épiceries fines ou alors carrément à
votre pâtissier parce que nous les
professionnels on l'a déçu il ya
différentes sortes différentes soit pas
vous l'aurez ou à votre pâtissier aux
deux épiceries fines
maintenant voilà ça colle un non non ça
colle fois les belges et ouais mais je
fais on était un peu de bol pour que ce
soit bien mes alcool pour garder
l'accord va au fond mais c'est vrai
qu'on s'est toujours des fois on
s'envoie des trucs et comme il faut que
ce soit bien celle allait bel et bien
cet apéro voilà voilà
prends ça j'espère que c'est celle que
l'on a connue quand on était petits on
va voir ça allait goûtez moi ça vire au
[Musique]